okay this video playing cow from the US
let's see let's see Rui can I do
something else just make me do something
crazy thoughts the bird it's not so bad
really one of the better lines and more
among those totally obscure once it's
really it's really okay like it's got
this strong porn on on d4 that
compensates for a lot and now h5 looks
crazy I know I know but you want this
Bishop have some create five business
prevented and that's not a bad way to do
it sometimes if white goes for F for you
have Knight f6 G for this kind of
counter play you know this this whole
opening is really one of those that that
they are better than they look I mean
it's of course looking really wacky but
it is not that terrible
now Queen f3 looks a bit a bit annoying
here actually with Bishop f4 possibly
coming mmm yeah that's a bit of a
problem check okay not good
okay this is one of those cases where
you know if you lose the game it's
entirely your fault poo oh this looks
very tricky okay it's a maybe a case of
playing with fire with playing the birds
but okay it's a I just got one one
advantage it's really it's really a
fight it's nothing like shuffling pieces
around and playing for for some small
stuff one big point radio flex position
is the default bond that makes it
difficult for white to to do something
with the night on be 193 is not possible
and yeah my development and in general
it's not bad really okay i was thinking
Bishop g4 here if it takes noritake
there should be okay really I've got
decent development then and the Queen g3
there's bishop d6 and well your queen is
trapped I can maybe play 94 somehow but
it would still lead to the loss of a
pawn yeah maybe yeah maybe Queenie
forward I can play 97's not on the
problem on idea he decided to to
exchange okay so the question is where
to put this f5 probably or d7 now maybe
a five
seems to be a bit more active the end
bishop d to work coming or maybe a 3 B 4
Bishop b2 attacking this possible ok
let's continue to get get pieces into
play yeah I think you played this well
getting getting its pieces somewhat
better coordinated must connect the rook
somehow but not quite sure to g6 I don't
know
yeah bit unsure how to play this why do
white is just better here he's better
coordinated maybe maybe Bishop f5 wasn't
i wasn't right and I really not sure
some difficult okay maybe night t-72 c5
to e6 something like that could could be
helpful when f6 I light is not doing
anything check okay here okay the apt
wants to play Bishop f4 26 so I guess
hmm
good f7 hanging mm-hmm here and here a5
not much that I can do about it
king is seven knots not a big choice
here okay some groupie 8 a-5 for its not
looking good I probably firmly do this
is six
what I'm trying to do is stripping the
real almost impossible time morning yeah
trapping not really coupons or nothing
basically
check root g eight maybe I've got slight
come on to play with this check check
check check check o gauge to check him
and it's not great still but the game
continues check you should be five
little trick that was a self tricking or
no I'm pinned a stupid stupid plane just
why play for this silly tricks i'm an
idiot don't lead your take ah of course
of course it was probably not in any
case but this is just totally stupid
rook be aight i mean AFF know i have no
square further for the bishop though
jared is full of good young
check after after i got this developed i
thought i should be okay but I have some
serious weaknesses here g5 and yeah and
this is this as a mistake yeah I look if
I forgot rookie five picking up a piece
could have done that it wasn't even good
for a positional point of human even
tactically yeah amazing how problematic
this position is this is now I mean the
loss of the hustling rights and so on
now I played this plate as well I hope
that in this in this phase of the game I
maybe would be M would be able to yeah
to somehow better coordinate my position
so that I get some counter play but this
is a 6 is 2 for 2 quickie islands to
click yeah i think what i actually did
wrong here i typed i type this wrong in
the opening this this is not this is not
a really good young Queen e7 here
there's no rookie one yeah I don't know
pretty I'm pretty very difficult okay
thanks for watching